Here's the story of how I threw my life away.
Just kidding. But
I know that's probably what a lot of people who know me in real life
thought, and probably do still think.
I was a speech pathology and audiology major,
and that's just fancy terms for speech therapy
and also the hearing sciences.
And while I initially really enjoyed what I was doing,
I started to really not like what I was doing.
Anyone's familiar with the field,
they know it's a very high stress field,
and the major itself is very competitive,
very stressful,
because you're fighting for positions to get into grad school,
essentially. Anyways,
it was very taxing on me mentally and physically.
I was having panic attacks daily.
I was in therapy like, it was bad.
Then met my husband, and he.
When we were talking about what we wanted our future to look like,
he told me that he wanted me to be a stay at home mom.
And at the time, I absolutely rejected that idea,
because I was very feministically.
The funny thing with god is when you say no,
never, he goes,
oh, really?
Because my heart changed so radically for wanting to be in the home.
That was mainly based off of scripture,
because what is scripture?
Prioritize for women, the home.
While maybe I could go back and be a SLP assistant,
but I really don't want to.
I have absolutely no desire to be in the workforce.
Because I choose to prioritize my home.
And Lord willing, when my kids are fully grown and gone,
I will have some grandbabies to help them raise.
So my work's never done.